-You want to talk about
strategy because you...
-Yes. Yes.
-Again, you called this
last time.
And talk about what happened
in Michigan in 2018 and --
-Last November, we --
Michigan sadly went red
for Trump in 2016.
But this past November,
we brought it back to blue.
And we kicked out
all the Republicans
in the state capitol
and we got the governor,
lieutenant-governor, attorney
general, secretary of state,
and we kicked out
two Republicans, Congressmen,
in suburban Detroit --
and replaced them with
two Democratic women.
So Michigan is now back --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me tell you how we did it.
Here's how we did it.
Amd we got to do this
in states --
especially the swing states
next year.
Ballot proposals brought out
the people to vote last November
who may not have voted.
So we came up with this idea.
Let's get two ballot proposals.
Actually, this is Karl Rove's
and Bush's idea.
In 2004, they got 14 states
to put an amendment
on the ballot proposal
to ban gay marriage,
and it passed
in all 14 states,
and it brought out enough people
to get Bush elected.
We can do this this time.
If we put ballot measures
on the ballots.
We did it in Michigan with
with marijuana legalization,
we doubled the youth vote...
-Yeah.
-...from the previous
off-year election.
And -- and the African-American
vote,
which thousands had sat it out
in '16,
unhappy with the choices,
came back to vote
last November
because we had a ballot proposal
to make gerrymandering
and voter suppression illegal,
and it passed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It passed, marijuana passed,
and we had a huge
African-American turnout,
and that gave us --
we got Democrats elected off it.
So instead of putting all
our hopes in one politician
to carry the thing, we have to
get these ballot proposals on
in the swing states.
That will bring out people
to vote.
Now, I tweeted at Trump
just before I came out
to watch tonight.
-Oh, wow. Okay, gotcha.
-You know, because I was
going to tell him, you know --
You think he is --
[ Laughter ]
He's like -- I told --
-Thank you.
-I told him to get
a bucket of KFC.
-Yep.
-And he's in his robe right now
watching you and I.
-Yeah, probably, yeah.
-And I said, you got to watch
because I'm going to tell you
how we're going remove you
from the White House next year.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we're gonna do it --
we're gonna do it
by getting those ballot
proposals in those states
to bring out the majority
of Americans, or that 70% --
women, people of color,
young adults.
We're going to run
a beloved candidate
who is a street fighter.
All right, I'm serious.
Folks, if we put up
the wrong horse in this race,
we are doomed again.
Let's not do that.
And I'm willing to say --
okay, so let's say --
Obviously I love Bernie
and his politics and all that,
but we all have to agree
we're going to all vote
for the person that isn't
just going to beat Trump,
'cause I think there's
four or five candidates now
that could beat him.
But beating isn't good enough.
Hillary beat him.
We have to crush Trump.
It has to be orange crush.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Orange crush.
Operation Orange Crush --
I just came up with that.
-There you go.
Well, you got to
come back again.
We'll check in on the operation.
That's Michael Moore, everybody.